un terrain de football en apparence
banale un site pollué par des engrais
chimiques selon le ministère de
l'environnement dans son recensement du
31 décembre 92
seul problème la coface la fabrique
d'engrais a fermé son usine en 75 et
assaini les terrains en 80 pour la
bagatelle de 700 mille francs
tous les rapports d expertise du bureau
de recherches géologiques le prouve à
mondeville on a beau avoir l'étiquette
socialiste comme son ministre
on goûte assez peu l'étiquette de
pollueurs je dis que c'est infantile de
traiter le problème de l'environnement
comme ça c'est infantile on n'a pas idée
de de lancer comme ça en l'air sans
savoir sans anbar contrôler la
dépollution
c'est un acte scientifique rigoureux ce
n'est pas seulement du verbiage et je
leur dis c'est que des techniciens des
spécialistes ont fait un bon travail sur
le site de l'usiné on a remplacé la
terre polluée par de la terre de la
plaine de caen puis on a placé un film
plastique pour empêcher tout contact
avec la nappe phréatique au conseil
régional de basse normandie on constate
ici que paris est en campagne quand
minus rose de la politique sera normal
ce qui l'est moins c'est qu'en
l'occurrence ce soit contre son camp
enfin c'est ce qui se dit à mondeville
où les électeurs tranquille n'ont guère
apprécié d'être pris pour ce qu'ils ne
sont pas d polluée